vous avez vu mimie mathy mimie mathy qui
est parti alors là dit elle a dit ce
qu'elle pense et mimie mathy elle refuse
catégoriquement de payer ces stations
stationnement au parc m c'est trop nord
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr qu'il fera le souffle comme ça
que certains non mais arrêtez et six
mois dit pas de bêtise
j'adore me mirent nador mathy on adore
mimie mathy momoa dans cette base alors
on a également dit elle a également dit
je ne vois pas pourquoi je ne vois pas
pourquoi dans le sud de la france il n'y
a pas de stationnement payant est à
paris au casque systématiquement donc
elle a dit voilà qu'elle ne paierait pas
est-ce que vous aussi vous frodebu et
réussit une info c'est l'info du jour
tout le monde en a parlé mimie mathy qui
payent pas les parcs m aujourd'hui
sachez le il ya des gars qui tue lui
colle au cul de sa voiture pour voir si
elles payent les parcs ne sais pas j'ai
vu là d'un lymphome à mimie mathy et ben
je vous jure en voiture elle déconne pas
elle est là la cua mehdi baala et suave
et voilà ah bon c'est vraiment plus oui
mais non en fait été dans une marque
mais je crois que ça y est vous y
connaissez parfaitement en sécurité
routière du coup elle paye
systématiquement des amendes exactement
merci oui m 2 comme on dit je croyais
que julien courbet bah oui elle paye des
âmes en peine d amende
bah oui mais elle préfère payer des
amendes que pn par savez quoi mimi match
aller comme ça et c'est pour ça que
j'aime mimie mathy bras mimie mathy 1
c'est une rebelle elle l aime pas un
truc elle dit bah voila c koi pas je
perds et les amendes voilà mes veaux
parcmètres vous bien sûr je paye mais
parfois bien sûr 15 minutes ce qui s'est
passé votre chauffeur et le fil avec en
warning bien sûr mais oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il ya mathieu non je me je me doutais
bonsoir enseigner c'est combien par
exemple 10 minutes ou 20 minutes à paris
pour papeete
ouais 2 euros 50 ça dépend des zones oui
disons 50 pour 20 minutes que je sais
pas parce que moi j'ai tchouga je reste
très rarement donné je ne m'arrête
jamais entre mobile mais oui je suis
souvent plus souvent en vo et entre
voitures oui en question de kelly b2b
minima qui ne payent pas de ces amendes
à chaque fois parce qu'elle se fait pas
prendre à chaque fois et moi je fais la
même chose tu ne payes jamais et la
technique c'est que le jour où tu as la
main de sa remboursera jamais tout ce
que tu as frauder c'est comme le métro
bank témoin là chaque fois derrière les
bleus n'ont jamais voulu tuer suite
le jour où tu à l'amande mais ça ne
remboursera jamais qu'on est en direct
et l'ambiance on attendait ça veut dire
très grave et d'un compte dont l'équipe
la colle m wacom mais madame bien sûr
normal cela dit cela dit à sa décharge
non classé c'est vrai que ça valait le
coup à l'époque où les l'amande est à 17
euros peu élevé mais du coup cet accueil
chaque scout est à peu près le même le
même prix que si vous restiez très
longtemps sur la place de parking ou
d'augmenter ses différentes et le et la
mini se colle dans le métro aussi
première fois pas le métro que j'ai
passé à miami
[Applaudissements]
à